how important was it to you to make a
feature film before you turn 30 yeah no
I mean it was it was very important I
mean like I mean I didn't want to make a
feature like at like at 19 I was trying
to make a feature at 22 23 I was trying
to make a feature they're all different
movies and then at 20 yeah at 24 I was
trying to make another feature then then
25 I spent a year trying and now that
was that one got the furthest and you
know we had a sizzle reel that we shot
we had a pitch package we had like a
business plan we had a script you know
we had a lot of like just a lot of stuff
package for that movie but you know like
that we would have people come on they
would fall off and we just couldn't get
you know I was like a $200,000 car you
know they probably needed like we're
only $200,000 it was like 25 locations a
lot of more interior was like another
desert movie and I think I took a lot of
that stuff and put inside of drifter
like a lot of thematic step of that
movie just made it if they're a little
more cheaper a little more accessible
and but but yeah I mean I spent like a
year on that movie throughout 2013 and
them and you know I you know a lot
people you know some people responded to
the script some people didn't some
people just didn't get it you know
because it wasn't very like plot heavy
it was very uh it was very like sort of
like a character driven story like just
this really kind of like whacked-out
cross-country story sort of like goes
from like California to Texas and like
and you know III think you know just you
know just we just at a certain point I
was like oh yeah I gotta I gotta I gotta
drop this one and then I made a couple
shorts out of frustration it'd be
creatively stimulated and then and then
you know I was like 27 that's like when
I decided to make a just jump into it
with drifter and I was like just set the
dates I was like got locked in dates
over I'm just gonna just ban this thing
out and just just just just you know at
least I can have a movie what a feature
film runtime you know it's like I can at
least have a feature under my belt you
know you know might not be amazing but I
have a feature technically so it's like
that's that's that was just very very
important to me to make a feature film
as soon as
you know and but it's like there's
always sorry someone out there that made
that feature before you or something
it's like you know stone soda burgers
like 25 or 26
you know Scorsese you know it's like
there's always always someone out there
like beat you to the punch or something
but but you know like that I I think
well you know because I spend a lot of
time acting so it's like and I just I
was focusing on that for a while and
then but yeah I was it was very very
important for me to make it you know it
to make a feature like before I was 30
very important to me
did you crowd fun for drifter uh-huh
what happened I mean just it just wasn't
you know I just wasn't successful at all
we just it was like an embarrassingly
unsuccessful but it was just like you
know I realized I mean like it just
wasn't the kind of movie that and I may
I'll never do that stuff ever again I
mean I kind of felt really bad about
even starting that campaign I just
didn't feel like that movie lend itself
to that kind of campaign very well
because it was just all I was trying to
make was like just a really
psychologically like disturbing cannibal
movie and like and and that's not what
and we didn't have any hook like I mean
some people were like familiar with a
couple shorts that maybe like we didn't
we didn't have any hook like we didn't
we didn't have like a big John reactor
attached we didn't it wasn't based on
like a video game or like a graphic
novel or anything it was just like just
was what it was and and you know there
was just no hook to it and and and so I
think like that so so it just ended up
being like just like a lot of like yeah
there were some like side you know nice
donators and all that like you know a
lot of it was personal sacrifice
you know just which yeah I mean I don't
I don't know if I recommend that to a
lot of filmmakers to do that and and a
lot of filmmakers have a lot of success
crowdfunding and all that and and I I
just never really understood how they
even do that you know I just I I never
understood like the mystery of IndieGoGo
and like Kickstarter I just don't I I
don't get it like I don't understand how
they get this money I just don't and so
I've never had any success with like any
sort those craft funding campaigns and
I've tried a couple including that one I
just haven't had any success with them
and so just but it was like you know I
was like you know what I'm not gonna
like just drop this
and then just cuz like I've you know i
don't i just i just especially that
sound like I needed to make a feature
like I just and if I was gonna like you
know I just lived like really cheaply
and just lived really like uncomfortably
you know and and just so I could save
money and just like put it all towards
the movie and them but ya know
you